this is actress brie Larson and yes
she's pushing a jeep but when she
started her demanding physical training
for Captain Marvel she couldn't even do
a proper push-up
according to her trainer Larson joins
the Marvel Cinematic Universe as Carol
Danvers and Captain Marvel to prepare
for this career defining role Larson has
to get in shape she trained with Jason
Walsh
he runs rise movement and rise nation in
Los Angeles the man who's helped actors
like Matt Damon John Krasinski Emily
Blunt and Alison Brie trained for
physically demanding roles my gofer for
Bree was to get her resilience
super-strong so that she can actually
you know do the stunts and walk away and
not did not get injured so how did Walsh
get Larson in such good shape for this
role it wasn't easy
Larson trained with Walt for about nine
months
before Captain Marvel started shooting
she started her career as an indie
darling gaining critical acclaim for
movies like short term 12 and then
eventually won an Oscar for her
performance in room playing a superhero
is unlike anything she's done before it
was a highly physical role obviously
she's a superhero so what you want to
take into consideration is the day-in
day-out physical aspects the stunt work
is gonna you know take place she wanted
to do most of the stunts Larson's
Instagram videos of her workouts have
gone viral
but getting to this point was a battle
so upper body strength is very very
important for breathe she came in she
couldn't
one pushup so we had a surf from the
very very beginning on this people see
the highlights and think that that's
just something that we kind of just
jumped into this is something that takes
time you know like I had you know three
cycles with her you know at three-month
periods where I was able to progress her
each time and it took nine months to get
her to a point where she was doing
chained push-ups and things like that
Walsh and Elissa Shoji another trainer
demonstrated how some of Larsen's
workouts progressed over time one of the
staples that we use here at Rice
movement is the hip thrust and we do use
it for a lot for warmups and sometimes
we use it like in Brie's case or use it
as a staple exercise where you get up to
like 400 pounds on the hip thrust but
like anything you need to start from the
bare basics learn the movement nice and
slow on the tempos none of this needs to
be fast the next progression we like to
do is to get a bar across the waist here
and this is great because we can track
our progress with the actual weight
[Music]
in order to get to the point where she
can start from the top go to the bottom
and go to the push-up correctly we
worked on progressions I want the five
the hands spread about five degrees out
and with the elbows to come back about
45 degrees the hips up and engaged here
once Larsson could do perfect push-ups
one of the highlights we got to with
Bria she got strong enough but we're a
certain amount of time that we can do
change push-ups and that's about 50
pounds with the change as she lowers all
the way to the ground
he gets lighter that she pushes up
dynamically it's a little bit heavier
[Music]
[Music]
then you'd finish with a few more
regular push-ups under fatigue condition
Walsh also encourages all sorts of
recreational activities
he usually tailors workouts to be actors
role for instance he made sure Emily
Blunt was able to handle wearing and
moving around in a 70 pound exoskeleton
and edge of tomorrow he made sure
Bradley Cooper was ready to carry around
heavy gear while shooting in desert
conditions for American sniper when he
trained with Alison Brie prior to glow
he added exercises to a regimen that
would prepare her for the show's
wrestling scenes Walsh's job wasn't the
Train Larson for the actual stunts in
fight to see or do in the movie his job
was to prepare her so she could then
train for that all the little workout
she did would perfectly lend themselves
for hand-to-hand combat I want the body
to work as a unit everything that we're
doing is generally speaking full-body
workouts multiplanar multi-joint
exercises you're able to learn how to
connect the foot and the hip
and the arms you know you're gonna be
able to throw a punch a lot better than
you are if you're just sitting there
doing like a bunch of bench press or
bicep curls her fight training was a mix
of Taekwondo judo and boxing over time
Larsson saw some surprising changes it's
it's pretty funny actually the costume
designer was becoming very annoyed with
us because as we were progressing she
was getting stronger she was actually
getting smaller because she was becoming
denser and denser and denser so they
actually had to take this suit and keep
taking it in from the Avengers to the
point when we started shooting Captain
Marvel
she was probably half her size but she
was 10 times stronger than she was when
she started as we mentioned earlier she
was even able to push a Jeep by the end
she saw a video of me doing a stupid
exercise where I was pulling my Jeep and
of course she got it in her mind that
she wanted to be able to push the Jeep I
told her if I see a certain level of
progression and strength from her and I
felt confident then noise I absolutely
wish she was hit thrust in front of
pounds she was doing everything
surpassed everything that I had really
anticipated she was just hungry for she
was ill of the challenges she insisted
and I felt like it was a safe enough
environment we control the environment
and she pushed this 5,000 pound Jeep up
you know a slight grade in the back
alley of my studio you know the most
rewarding thing for me is to see
somebody really start to adhere and
absorb and appreciate what strength
training can do for for you being
pain-free being strong doing things that
you really just didn't think was
possible for you Bri was one of those I
think she's she's a lifer